[Musik]
im märz steht vor der tür und wir können
wieder jede menge sachen aussehen und
was das genau ist das zeige ich dir in
diesem video wir starten mit dem
wahrscheinlich beste gemüse überhaupt
mit den tomaten denn ab mitte märz
kannst du auch deine freiland tomaten
vorziehen ich habe ja im februar video
schon gesagt dass wir die gewächshaus
tomaten teilweise schon im april
pflanzen und die freiland tomaten dann
mitte mai das heißt die gewächshaus
tomaten könnt ihr jetzt auch schon
anfang märz oder ende februar vorziehen
aber die freiland tomaten da warte
lieber noch ab weil das tut den nicht
gut wenn sie so lange im haus ausharren
müssen bis sie dann endlich nach draußen
gepflanzt werden könnt und ich
verspreche euch es kommt auf dem kanal
auch wieder einen tomaten anzucht video
wo ich euch genau schritt für schritt
zeige wie das funktioniert so dass sie
am ende ganz viele tolle tomaten ernten
könnt und richtig schön kräftige
pflanzen in euren garten pflanzt also an
dem video arbeite ich jetzt schon es
kommt rechtzeitig online bevor ihr eure
tomaten auswählen müsst also wartet noch
bis zu diesem video abonniert den kanal
damit ihr das nicht verpasst und dann
machen wir das zusammen und zwar richtig
wenn dann ein ganz ähnliches gemüse wo
ihr euch nicht so an gedulden müssen
sind die auberginen die könnt ihr schon
aussehen bzw eigentlich sehe ich die
sogar schon im februar und januar aus so
dass sie dann rechtzeitig richtig schön
groß werden weil die wachsende ein
bisschen langsamer als die tomaten das
heißt sie brauchen ein bisschen mehr
zeit in der anzucht und wenn ihr eure
auberginen noch nicht gewählt habt dann
macht das jetzt auf jeden fall ist es
geht jetzt natürlich um die anzucht im
haus jetzt ist es draußen noch viel zu
kalt um da diese ganzen wärmeliebenden
pflanzen aus zu sehen sie jetzt im haus
vorziehen und dann erst mitte mai nach
den eisheiligen auspflanzen das gleiche
gilt für die paprika wobei es jetzt
schon relativ spät ist und paprika aus
zu sehen aber wenn ihr noch keine
paprika ausgewählt habt dann macht das
jetzt auf jeden fall ein sorten tipp von
mir verdi jolo wanda das ist eine tolle
glocken paprika allerdings eher fürs
gewächshaus wenn ihr freiland paprika
anbauen möchte das funktioniert je
nachdem wo man holt auch ziemlich gut
das kann ich auf jeden fall mal
ausprobiert habe ich super erfahrungen
mit der sorte rote augsburger gemacht
die machen natürlich nicht so dicke und
runde paprika wie man sie aus dem
supermarkt kennt das funktioniert im
freien nur so mäßig je nach sorte
sondern ihr spitze ein bisschen kleinere
ein bisschen dünnwandige paprika nie
aber genauso lecker schmecken und die
geborgenheit er ist auch aussehen das
ist ja auch so ein gemüse was man nicht
so oft im supermarkt sieht das eine aber
super frühe mir eine super leckere und
tolle ernte beschert und wir sehen
unsere dicken bohnen immer im herbst
oder im spätsommer ihr aus dem september
august damit die schon ein bisschen vor
dem winter ein bisschen groß werden
können und im beet überwintern weil die
sind sehr frosthart aber man kann eben
jetzt auch noch dicke bohnen sehen und
man kriegt ein bisschen spätere ernte
aber es ist immer noch ein super
zeitpunkt um die bei euch im garten
auszusehen und wir bauen am
allerliebsten die sorte hängen da und
grünkern kann und für erbsen ist jetzt
auch eine tolle zeit die muss man nicht
im haus vorziehen senden die kann man
direkt nach draußen sehen ich schaue
immer dass es so unfair in die nächsten
zwei wochen so weit wie die
wettervorschau geht kein frost geben
soll bevor ich sachen nach draußen sehr
da kamen ja jetzt auch viele fragen wie
mache ich das denn gesagt wir können
viel bruders und das sehen aber das
kommt natürlich ganz darauf an wie es
draußen aussieht also wenn ganz viel
schnee liegt so wie jetzt die letzten
zwei drei wochen dann erstmal ein
bisschen gedulden drin noch ein bisschen
gemütlich machen und er auf die anzucht
konzentrieren aber sobald es draußen ein
bisschen wärmer wird so bald keine feste
mehr angekündigt sind könnt ihr diese
sachen die ich euch jetzt die sage auch
schon nach draußen sehen ich war da noch
moment aber ich denke so in zwei wochen
mache ich auch weiter mit den aussagen
im freiland und da könnt ihr sowohl marc
erbsen da sehe ich ganz gern die sorte
ambassador als auch zuckererbsen serien
zuckererbsen sind meiner erfahrung nach
ein bisschen frost härter deswegen
kommen die bei mir schon ein bisschen
früher ins bett aber die markierten
packen das jetzt auch schon und
natürlich ist es nicht schlimm wenn es
dann nochmal frost gibt und die pflanzen
schon aufgegangen sind weil die ganzen
gemüse die man jetzt draußen aussehen
kann und die ich euch hier vorstellen
die können das ab aber ich warte eben
wenn sie gerade ausgesetzt sind versuche
ich es so abzupassen dass sie wenigstens
so ein zwei wochen haben bevor dann der
erste frost wieder reinhaut sie ein
bisschen auflaufen können machen wir
weiter mit dem kohlgemüse und da geht es
jetzt zum beispiel flora sports aussehen
das ist eine neue kreuzung aus grünkohl
und rosenkohl die schmecken super lecker
sind super hübsch und eigentlich ihren
wintergemüse habe man kann jetzt auch
schon anfangen aber mit den first post
könnt ihr euch auch noch zeit lassen die
kann man auch noch ich glaube zwei oder
so aussehen gucke mal ja bis mai kann
man die auch noch vorziehen also das
wäre jetzt nicht so ähnlich aber ein
gemüse dass ich sehr gerne früh im jahr
an bauer ist der brokkoli da haben wir
jetzt auch schon die letzten monate
immer fleißig was vorgezogen und der
wandert bei mir jetzt auch wieder in die
erde so dass wir laufend aus dem garten
und seine eigenen folianten können das
jetzt noch die sorte linda für den
frühen anbau aber da kann man jetzt auch
bald zu anderen sorten übergehen die
nicht ganz so früh sind genauso sieht es
beim weißkohl aus da haben wir jetzt
auch immer die sorte nagels früh weiß
ausgesät und da gehe ich jetzt langsam
über zu herbst weißkohl da sehe ich
jetzt langsam die sorte thomaner im haus
vor weil dies dann eher für die späte
ernte gedacht im herbst auch für die
sauerkraut herstellung das ist einfach
eine andere qualität also dieser schnell
wachsende weißkohl der richtig schnell
dicke köpfe bildet die man dann früh im
jahr ernten kann der enthält natürlich
viel mehr wasser und macht ein viel
weicheres matschiges sauerkraut als der
langsam wachsende herbst weißkohl also
die sorte thomaner zum beispiel da gibt
es natürlich auch viele andere tolle
somit die haben wir gute erfahrungen
gemacht die sich zeit nimmt und dann
einfach ein knackiges festes lange
haltbare sauerkraut ergibt da kann man
dann also durchwechseln im jahresverlauf
je nachdem was man will je nachdem wie
ich früher oder später die sorten sind
kann man da abwechseln und wir haben da
eine ganz gute liste mit sorten die sich
super gut ergänzen und die wir zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten im jahr bei uns
im garten anbauen und dann habe ich euch
ja im letzten video schon erzählt dass
man jetzt auch tat sehen kann dass es
ein tolles asiatisches wintergemüse
ziemlich lecker ziemlich frosthart und
den könnt ihr jetzt sogar auch im
freiland aussehen also die müsste jetzt
gar nicht mehr unbedingt im haus
vorziehen und mit kohlrabi geht es jetzt
auch weiter den könnt ihr sowohl im haus
vorziehen und dann später raus pflanzen
als auch je nach sorte und wetter
schauen direkt ins knoblauch geht jetzt
auch wunderbar ich habe ja ein video zum
knoblauch pflanzen auf meinem kanal also
schaut euch das auf jeden fall mal an
und dann geht raus und stärkt euren
knoblauch verknüpft ist so ziemlich das
einfachste gemüse was ihr bei euch im
garten anbauen könnt und wenn ihr
knoblauch mild dann könnt ihr davon
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht genug
haben man kann sehr leicht seinen
eigenen knoblauch selbstversorger vorrat
für ein jahr an bauen beim jong chol
gehen wir jetzt auch zu einer anderen
sorte über wir haben ja letztes mal die
sorte oder service gesehen dass es ein
ganz ganz früher blumenkohl und jetzt
sehe ich die sorte eine kapelle die
ziehe ich auch im haus vor dabei immer
beachten dass man die wenn man die
pikiert also wenn man die vom aus
tschechien in eigene töpfchen und
pflanzt dass man die dann ein bisschen
tiefer setzt also ich bis zu den wo die
ersten blätter herauskommt so dass sie
einfach ein bisschen mehr
standfestigkeit haben das tut kohl
eigentlich immer ganz gut bei anderen
pflanzen wie zum beispiel salat würde
ich das dann aber nicht machen weil das
könnte dazu vollen ist führen aber zum
beispiel tomaten mögen das auch
christian von rotkohl geht jetzt auch
sowohl im haus als auch im freiland
meine lieblingssorte ist die sorte
granat ich mein bild hier auf dem
tütchen für euch und da bin ich mir
immer unsicher es ist einerseits finde
ich es total sinnvoll so viel gemüse wie
möglich direkt ins beet zu sehen weil
die pflanzen dann einfach kräftiger
werden weil sie mich umgepflanzt werden
mussten sich die wurzeln nicht in ihrem
köpfchen gekräuselt haben so dass sie
später wenn sie im boden gepflanzt
werden gar nicht so ein kräftiges tiefes
wurzelwerk entwickeln können und gar
nicht so tiefe bodenschichten
erschließen können um sich ihr wasser
aus tieferen schichten zu holen
andererseits ist der fans ab stand bei
kopfkohl so wichtig damit die sich schön
entwickeln und das kann man wenn man sie
direkt ins beet finde ich ziemlich
schwer nur regulieren deswegen ziehe ich
sie eher im haus vor wir können ja mal
erzählen wie ihr das handhabt aber ich
entscheide mich dann meistens doch dafür
dass ich den er im haus fort sie als ihn
direkt ins beet zu sehen ich bin ja ein
großer freund von speck zwiebel mehr
einerseits weil ich so ein bisschen faul
bin und das praktisch ist wenn man
einfach so im netz zwiebeln kauft die in
die erde steckt das ist viel einfacher
die zu stecken als wenn man welche
vorzieht und pflanzt beim serien findet
man sie direkt in speed serie dann
werden sie nicht so dick wie mein stack
zwiebeln steckt aber das geht jetzt
beides also ihr könnt so hohe steck
zwiebeln kaufen und die bei euch ins
beet stecken das mache ich auf jeden
fall sehr sehr gerne allerdings lassen
sich die gesteckten zwiebel nicht so gut
lagern wie die man direkt aussieht oder
wie man vorgezogen hatten dann pflanzt
wie machen so einen guten mix aus beidem
und versuchen die gesteckten zwiebeln
daneben früher im jahr auf zu essen
wobei die sich auch bis februar
verlagern es ja auch schon nicht
schlecht die sollte stuttgarter riesen
kann ich euch wie immer empfehlen
ansonsten wird weiß nicht mal wie man es
ausspricht erdbeeren das ist eine tonne
lagerfähige sollte und wird er ganz
schön wenn man ein paar gelbe und rote
zwiebeln hat oder die schmecken ja auch
unterschiedlich und wir machen weiter
mit dem lauch und da könnt ihr jetzt
auch schon den winterlauf vorziehen
letztes mal wer kaufe ich wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere den sommerlauf
vorgezogen die sorte dairy bauen wir da
ganz gerne an summen in den warmen
monaten kann aber laut es auch so ein
bisschen ein langsamerer typ also wenn
wir den jetzt vielleicht in einem jahr
ernten wollt wenn wieder winter ist und
der immer noch auf euren beten stehen
soll dann wäre es jetzt schon zeit den
langsam mal im haus vorzuziehen und da
baue ich ganz gern die sorte blaugrüner
winter an das ist eine ganz frostharte
und ertragreiche sorten die sich bei uns
ziemlich tapfer schlägt die wir sicher
schon seit sechs jahren anbau und ich
nehme auch mal wieder den schnitt
knoblauch rein da einfach um mal ein
anderes gemüse vorzustellen das
vielleicht nicht so viele von euch
kennen denke die jetzt auch seele nichts
ideen im haus vor pflanzen dann später
nach draußen das habe ich ja schon im
februar video gemacht der schmeckt
ähnlich wie knoblauch aber sieht aus wie
schnittlauch also ist sozusagen ein
schnitt auf der nach knoblauch schmeckt
der frost hat ist und eine ganz tolle
sache und der salat ist jetzt auch
wieder am start ich habe jetzt meinen
sorten max rausgesucht aus
unterschiedlichen roten und grünen asia
salatsorten
das ist super cool weil die machen
richtig was wir also die sie in super
hübsch aus im beet sind super frost hat
er sie könnte jetzt auch aussehen wenn
es bei euch noch ein bisschen kälter ist
sind ruckzuck ernte bereit ist rundum
eine tolle sache dieses mädchen ist
schon ziemlich zerfleddert aber
vielleicht erkennt ihr trotzdem worum es
geht um mangold natürlich und den werde
ich jetzt gerade noch nicht nach draußen
sehr genau das ist super war und es sind
super warme temperaturen angekündigt da
würde ich noch bis april ungefähr warten
aber im haus könnt ihr mann gold auf
jeden fall schon vorziehen ich habe
gerade auch welchen in meinem anzug
regal stehen das ist nur super sache um
die ernte ein bisschen zu früh das ist
ja in gemüse was man super früh lernen
kann und dann geht es eben doch ein
bisschen schneller und man kann diese
lernte lücke die man so habe ich als er
den mann so im mai und juni hat bis die
gemüse so richtig ranklotzen und man ist
erst mal so richtig vollen ernte corp
hat super schließen mit solchen schnell
wachsenden blattgemüse genauso wie mit
salat salat wächst ja auch super gut
gerade wenn man ein bisschen schützt ich
stehe zum beispiel gab es gern einfach
mal ein marmeladenglas über meine frisch
gepflanzten pflänzchen wenn es draußen
noch so kalt ist das ist wie mini
gewächshaus wenn man selbst keines hat
und das funktioniert super gut und dann
ganz früh im jahr schon als erste grün
zu ernten auch eine sorte ich weiß nicht
ob ich schon meinen polen habe aber die
ich super gern mag gemacht so ganz feste
tolle grüne köpfe ist die sorte little
gem baue ich seit meinem allerersten
gartenjahr an wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere und ein absoluter favorit bei
uns im garten den sehe ich jetzt erstmal
im haus vor um ihnen dann nach draußen
zu pflanzen aber wenn ihr schon salat
vorgezogen habe der jetzt bei euch steht
dann könnt ihr den die nach wetter jetzt
auch schon abhärten also an das draußen
leben gewöhnen mein tag nach draußen
stellen den schatten so dass er sich an
die temperaturunterschiede gewöhnen kann
und dann nach und nach ein bisschen mehr
in die sonne schieben weil die können
auch sonnenbrand bekommen die kleinen
jungen pflänzchen wenn man nicht auf die
aufpasst und die müssen sich erst nach
und nach an das draußen leben gewöhnt
und salat ist und kann die dinge im netz
auch schon super gut einfach ins
freiland pflanzen könnt ich schütze
denen ganz gerne mit dem winter fliesst
falls es noch mal kalt werden sollte um
ein bisschen ein zum bummeln aber da
steckt echt mehr weg als man denken mag
gerade wenn man ihr die frost härteren
sorten wie back oder winter marie anbaut
jetzt habe ich noch mal einen kandidaten
für euch dabei um das ganze ein bisschen
aufzupeppen und mal über andere sachen
zu reden als sonst immer das ist die
rote melde die bauen wir jedes jahr an
die setzt sich auch bei uns einfach
immer wieder neu im garten aus so dass
wir die jetzt gar nicht aussehen die
macht das ganz von alleine das ist eine
verwandte der normalen garten melde wie
könnt ihr vielleicht auch als unkraut
aber die schmeckt super lecker sowohl
die grünen als auch die rote ich finde
nur die rote macht noch ein bisschen
mehr hier im weg da muss man aufpassen
mit den jahren kreuzt sich die grüne
garten melde immer wieder ein wenn man
die selbe aussehen lässt und dann kriegt
man irgendwann gefleckt oder halb rote
aber das macht mir auf jeden fall
überhaupt nichts und ich find's super
schön wenn man einfach so ein paar rote
plättchen im salat hat und außerdem
schmecken die auch richtig lecker also
die sind ganz zart vor allem wenn man
die jungen erntet oder die köpfe erntet
oben an der pflanze es ist wirklich ein
ganz tolles gemüse kann man auch die
spieler zum kochen verwenden oder
lasagne draus machen schumacher und
eingewiesen dem es überhaupt nichts
ausmacht wenn es draußen jetzt
vielleicht noch ein bisschen kalt ist im
gegenteil sind die posten
das ist ein eher unbekanntes salat
ähnliches gemüse ich es die super gerne
schmecken auch sehr mild eigentlich so
ein bisschen wie melde zahlt man kann da
super einen salat draus machen und vor
allem sind die sau gesund also die sind
gerade in den kalten monaten wenn man
nicht so viele andere frische sachen ist
ein richtiger vitaminbombe und postel
ein keim zum beispiel wenn es kalt ist
also die brauchen temperaturen unter 15
grad damit sie überhaupt aufgehen können
die basteleien sind eigentlich eher dazu
gedacht dass man sie spät im jahr
ausfällt also im august und september
ungefähr und dann im winter erntet aber
ich habe eben die erfahrung gemacht dass
wenn man sie früh im jahr aussieht dass
man dann auch noch früh um mir eine
kleine ernte kriegen kann bevor sie in
die blüte gehen aber dann kann man eben
auch sein eigenes saatgut von den
pflanzen nehmen deswegen finde ich das
kleine rote beete kann dort auch wieder
im haus vorziehen ich würde auch wie
beim mangold auch die sind ja auch eng
miteinander verband wusstet ihr
eigentlich da werde ich jetzt mit der
freiland aus hat vielleicht noch moment
warten aus es ist super waren bei euch
vielleicht das ende märz kann man die
schon direkt ins freie aussehen aber im
haus könnt ihr die jetzt schon vorziehen
und dann raus pflanzen um die ernte eben
ein bisschen zu verfrüht und auch mit
mangold und rote beete verband ist der
spieler der ist ein bisschen härter
drauf also den könnt ihr jetzt auch
schon ins freiland serien oder ihn im
haus vorziehen aber das finde ich bei
spinat oft ein bisschen zu aufwändig
deswegen bin ich eher dafür gehen direkt
ins freiland zu sehen der pakt dass der
ist genauso forst hat wie ich da machen
wir weiter mit einer anderen roten
knolle und zwar dem radieschen
radieschen gehen ja eigentlich fast das
ganze jahr über gerade wenn man
gewächshaus oder free bild kasten hat
also das lohnt sich auf jeden fall wenn
man ein bisschen geschützt darin war
auch noch im winter machen kann aber ich
spreche jetzt erst einmal nur über die
aussaat im freiland weil ich weiß dass
viele von euch das nicht haben und
radieschen könnt ihr mehr als auch schon
nach draußen serien radieschen sind ja
so ziemlich die am schnellsten
wachsenden gemüse überhaupt und da könnt
ihr dann auch schon ganz früh um ihre
allererste kleine winzige ernte
einfahren ein etwas langsamer kandidat
ist die pastinake was die nacken sehe
ich ganz früh im jahr aus also februar
und märz sind so unsere pastinaken
aussaat zeiten damit wir dann im winter
ganz viele dicken knollen ernten können
die brauchen einfach ein bisschen länger
genauso wie der knollensellerie den er
jetzt auch im haus vorziehen könnte
pastinaken nicht im haus vollziehen die
direkt nach draußen sehen auch wenn es
noch ein bisschen kälter ist das macht
ihn nicht so viel aus aber die würden es
nicht verkraften wenn man sie im haus
vollzieht und dann um pflanzt die sollen
ja eine lange gerade wurzel nach unten
gehen und wenn man die so an den wurzeln
stört das würde denen überhaupt nicht
gefallen das heißt die pastinake jetzt
nach draußen sehen auch wenn es ein
bisschen kälter draußen ist das packt
ihn und den knollensellerie den er als
auch aussehen könnt den sie hat er jetzt
im haus in töpfchen vor pikiert die dann
in einzelne töpfchen und pflanzt sie
dann erst später nach draußen und eng
mit der pastinake verwandt sind die
röhren und die könnte es auch aussehen
da findet langsam bei uns auch so ein
bisschen einen so harten wechsel statt
also im märz ist noch ein bisschen der
übergang von der sorte gonsenheimer
treibt es ist die hier die wir als frühe
aussaat aussehen für die schnell
wachsenden hören sie auch mit kälte
besser zurecht kommen und dann kommt die
sollte milan ins spiel die werden so ab
ende märz anfang april aussehen für
lager möhren und dickere mühe und
größere möhren da weg sind sich dann
auch diese beiden sorten ab und dann
kommt jetzt eine sorte die keine
empfehlung ist weil auch wieder so ein
tablett das tütchen aber ich habe gerade
keine andere tüte gefunden ihr könnt
nämlich jetzt auch rettich aussehen aber
eben nicht hier den runden schwarzen
winter weil der ist er für spätere
aussagen im jahr gedacht sondern da
würde ich dann ich eine frühere sorte
verwenden und nicht so eine explizite
winter sorgte und das gemüse das ich
seit jahren nicht mehr anbauen weil ich
es nicht hinkriegen das ist bei mir
wächst der fenchel da steht zumindest
auf ein tütchen drauf dass man den jetzt
auch wieder im haus vorziehen kann man
kann ihn auch ins gewächshaus sehen ich
habe welche vorgezogen sie sehen
jämmerlich aus aber vielleicht machen
sie sich ja noch ein bisschen ist es
normal dass die so lang gezogen und
schwächlich sind oder mache ich
irgendwas falsch also wenn ihr
irgendwelche kennt jeder anbau tipps
habt dann schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare weil ich will wirklich dass
es funktioniert dieses jahr und ich habe
keine ahnung was ich falsch mache oder
ob wir einfach nicht miteinander können
wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt ja was ist
denn eigentlich mit gurken kürbis
melonen zucchini und so weiter wo
bleiben die wann darf ich die ähnlich
aussehen
das sind kandidaten die richtig richtig
schnell wachsen auch in der anzucht und
deswegen war ich mit denen immer bis
vier wochen bevor sie gepflanzt werden
also ich sehe die erst mitte april aus
damit wie sie dann mitte mai nach
draußen pflanzen können wenn ich die
gurken schon ein bisschen früher ins
gewächshaus pflanzen will dann sehe ich
sie vielleicht ende märz aus aber das
ist wirklich sehr sehr früh also
vielleicht er anfang april deswegen hat
sind jetzt hier noch nicht vorgekommen
und kommen dann erst nächsten monat mit
dazu und dann erzähle ich euch auch noch
mehr dazu wie das funktioniert aber
geduldet euch noch ein bisschen für die
kandidaten es ist jetzt gerade auf jeden
fall noch viel zu früh
ja genau die kartoffel muss man jetzt
auch vorteile wenn ihr im april oder mai
ihre kartoffeln pflanzen wollte das ist
jetzt ganz gut wenn ihr die an einen
hellen ort liegt zb eine fensterbank wo
die schön viel licht bekommen und dann
ihre triebe bilden können ihr kennt das
vielleicht wenn der kartoffeln lagert
das die dann so lange weiße
zerbrechliche triebe bilden und das sind
nicht die triebe die wir wollen wenn wir
die kartoffeln vor keinen weg heim die
vor um den wenn wir sie aus bremsenden
wachstumsvorsprung zu verpassen so dass
sie schneller wachsen mehr zeit haben im
beet dann eine gute ernte abzuwerfen da
wollen wir kleine grüne kurze gedrungen
natürlich ist es nicht schlimm wenn ihr
die kartoffelpflanze jetzt schon die
weißen langen kaymer haben aber beim
vorteil mal so wenn man es perfekt
machen will dann sind wir auf die kurzen
gedrungenen grünen keime aus da könnt
ihr jetzt einfach die kartoffeln an der
fensterbank auslegen man kann ja auch
gut in eierkartons machen dass man sie
später auch besser transportieren kann
und dann sind sie im april oder mai je
nachdem wann ihr sie pflanzen volt
bereit in die erde zu wandern aber ich
habe hier noch ein paar tütchen für euch
und zwar weiter mit dem sauerampfer
sowohl der blutsauger sind es so schöne
route sauerampfer sorte als auch der
kultur sauerampfer dass wir dann die
grüne variante sind sehr schön france
thate leckere gemüse die man auch mit im
salat machen kann die sehr gesund sind
und ihr könnt ihr beide jetzt ins
freiland direkt aussehen und dann habe
ich noch basilikum für euch ich weiß das
ist nicht unbedingt geben sie das ist
aber es ist ein ziemlich cooles kraut
und ich wollte euch daran erinnern dass
ihr die jetzt auch im haus vorziehen
könnte siegel kommt es so eine
frostbeule also unter 15 grad findet er
ist schon ziemlich ungemütlich dh
frühestens mitte mai ihr ende mai können
wir diese kandidaten nach draußen
pflanzen ins freiland damit die sich
auch richtig wohlfühlen aber basilikum
ist auch so ein gemächlicher kandidaten
das heißt wer braucht seine zeit bis er
überhaupt in die pötte kommt und
deswegen ist es jetzt super den im haus
vorzuziehen ich ziehe da immer ein zwei
maximal drei pflänzchen in einem topf
vor ich habe den eindruck dass viele
leute unterschätzen wieviel platz
basilikum eigentlich braucht weil wenn
man den im laden kauft so einen topf
dann sind da ja mal ganz ganz viele
dicht an dicht aber basilikum schauen
wir mal was ihr drauf steht der will
einen pflanzabstand von 25 x 20
zentimeter pro einzelne pflanze damit er
richtig groß wird und damit man richtig
ertrag von dem bekommt das heißt eine
einzelne pflanze nimmt so viel raum ein
und wird so groß wie ein ganzer bus von
basilikum die man im supermarkt kauft
muss viel ertragreicher wenn man den
platz gibt weil sie dann viel länger
erhalten ihr kennt das bestimmt dass
diese top basilika es können das
listenfeld mir
super schnell sterben weil sie einfach
keinen platz haben in dem topf weil es
denen da nicht so gut geht und wenn die
eigentlich so einen großen abstand
wollen von 20 mal 25 zentimeter und man
denen den gibt dann kann man die immer
wiederkehrenden und man kann richtig
viel festzumachen und holt viel mehr aus
den pflanzen raus und wenn ihr lust habt
mal ein basilikum video zu sehen wo ich
euch die ganzen basilikum basilisken
tipps mit auf den weg geben dann
schreiben wir das gerne mal in die
kommentare der halte ich nämlich auf
jeden fall richtig lust drauf ich habe
hier noch ein paar andere tütchen mit
dabei um euch zu zeigen dass es nicht
nur in diesem standard basilikum mit
diesen dino wieser typ sondern eben auch
zum beispiel rote oder rot basilikum es
hat kleinere blätter und schmeckt anders
es gibt zitronen basilikum zum publikum
in allen möglichen
geschmacksrichtungen und das ist eine
ganz große vielfalt die man entdecken
kann wenn man das basilikum eben selbst
anbaut und nicht nur diese töpfe aus dem
supermarkt kauft da drüben findest du
eine playlist mit gartentipps und
wichtigen aufgaben die jetzt in deinem
garten fällig sind also schaut er gerne
vorbei
sehen wir uns nächste woche wieder biss
dann macht's gut